I want to do a very brief intro here I
was at Jordan Peterson's Arc conference
last week Arc Alliance for responsible
citizenship in London and it was a
three-day event it was invite only about
1500 people from all over the world 70
plus countries dignitaries politicians
media people all trying to solve the
problems of the day whether they were
about energy or politics or culture the
the laundry list of things that are
important that we're kind of not dealing
with appropriately the these days at the
end of the 3-day conference Jordan
Peterson gave a speech it's about a half
hour speech and I think it was the
single best speech I have ever heard
Jordan give in my life and as you guys
know I toured with Jordan for a year and
a half we did about 120 shows together
almost two dozen countries and the
speech was just absolutely inspiring I
don't know that there was a dry eye in
the entire venue and I wanted to share
it with you with permission from Jordan
and his his team and Arc completely
unedited so take a look we find
ourselves in the midst of a a so-called
culture War it's
a psychological and
social
Minefield and at this conference we've
been trying to weave our
way through that Minefield and to offer
something approximating
a a solution
that beckons
and is productive and
generous I want to investigate though a
little
further I want to investigate the the
essential feature of that war a little
further and while doing so I want to
wind together weave together the themes
of the
conference we're we're at odds with one
another about
identity and in order
to reduce the tension and bring
about a new psychological integration
and a proper social peace we can't
merely
criticize the suggestions about what
identity constitutes that have been
brought forward we have to offer an
alternative and so I would like to delve
deeply for half an hour
into what
identity must and should
be and to relate that to what social
structure must and should
be I opened the conference by pointing
out proposing that the two fundamental
themes that we would address would be
those of faith and respect
responsibility and I suggested
that faith is a faith is the kind of
Courage that allows you to welcome the
possibilities of the future with open
arms and and I say possibility because
the future is the manifestation of
possibility into actuality and the
possibility of the future is what we
contend with the the
unknown Treasure House of what could be
is what we contend with and given that
that's what we eternally contend with we
might ask ourselves how best to contend
with that and one answer to that is with
the faith that is simultaneously
courageous we put ourselves on the line
to act out the proposition that
existence itself being itself and
becoming itself are intrinsically good
and that it's incumbent upon us to act
in accordance with that dict
come hell or high
water and we look into the future and we
cast upon the unknown landscape of the
future a vision a a vision that provides
us with hope and security because that's
what a vision does and then we bear the
responsibility of attending and acting
in a manner that makes that hopeful and
security providing vision
possible and so then I would
say that identity is the proper Union of
faith and
responsibility and then you might
say how
does a proper identity unite faith and
responsibility and I would say that it
does that in a subsidiary manner in a
hierarchical subsidiary manner now if
you're beset with conflict subjectively
and in your Society about what identity
constitutes you need a counter position
that's welldeveloped
so identity is the proper Union of faith
and responsibility and proper identity
is subsidiary in structure all right so
let's take that apart first
slide now I'm going to tell you a little
story it's a very simple story but
simple stories scale upward and that's
Jacob's Ladder Jacob's Ladder that's the
Eternal lyan the vine that unites the
material and proximal Realm of the Earth
with the Eternal realm of
heaven and how do we construct and climb
Jacob's lad how do we comprehend it when
my son was one and a half years old
I taught him to set the
table but that's not right because when
you're one and a half you can't set the
table if you take a 2-year-old and you
say clean your
room to a 2-year-old who's in the midst
of a room that he's distributed a
terrible mess in and you come back in 15
minutes the room will be equally messy
and you'll ask your 2-year-old why
didn't you clean the room and he will
just look at you and the reason he will
just look at you is because he doesn't
know what clean your room means so you
can take the 2-year-old my son in this
case and you can say Hey
kid you see that teddy bear now he's
happy about that request hey because at
two he knows how to see a teddy bear and
so he'll Point his eyes at the teddy
bear and then he'll look at you and then
you can Pat him on the head and say good
and then you can say say go over there
and pick up that teddy bear so then he
does that and he looks at you and then
you can say you see that space on the
Shelf there he goes yes he says you take
that teddy bear and you put it in that
space in the shelf and he'll go over and
put it in the space in the shelf and
then he'll look at you and you can Pat
him on the head and then if you teach
him a 100 micro routines like that very
carefully you can tell him to clean his
room and he knows how to do it and
that's how we build ourselves and that's
a little vision it's a little vision you
it's a micro Vision
that the first vision is what the room
would look like if the teddy bear was
put in its proper space right and it's
not a glorious macro vision of how to
unite Heaven and Earth itself but it's
the proximal beginnings of exactly that
process
so we scaffold ourselves upward from the
finite to the infinite and it's the
entire scaffold that constitutes our
identity
so my son he's 18 months old I'm having
him help at the table I say
kid you know where the drawer is with
the knives and the forks and he says yes
I said go to that
drawer and open it up and pick out a
fork and so he goes and does that he can
feel the fork cuz he has the drawers
above him and he can feel the fork and
then he can come and say bring it into
the kitchen and put it on the table by
the plate and he can do that and then he
can do that with a knife and then he can
do that with a plate if you dare to let
him carry a plate and then he's learning
what he's learning to set the
table right and then he sits at the
table with the people that are there and
he's learning to share food and he's
learning to take turns and he's learning
to be hospitable right and so you can
see that that starts to scale upward
right and then he's hospit hitable and
he can take turns so he's starting to be
a good boy a good kid and that's part of
being taking his proper role in the
family which is a broader form of
sharing and the beginnings of his
ability to play properly with others and
then to take his position as a potential
friend in the community and then to
mature and as he matures the scale of
his vision expands step by step until it
encompasses
not merely what he wants in the short
term but what would be good for him in
the medium to long term so the temporal
scale of his vision expands and not only
so that he accomplishes or attains
what's good for him but so that he does
that in a way that incorporates more and
more other people into the expanse of
his vision and so by the time you start
to operate as an adult you can take
responsibility for yourself you know how
to be hospitable you know how to play
with others if you're fortunate or maybe
you still have to learn that within the
confines of your marriage and then you
take responsibility for your partner and
they do that with you and the two of you
take responsibility for your children
and that gives you the satisfaction and
the adventure and the responsibility and
the burden and the meaning of your
family and you embed that in your
community and you take responsibility
for that and you take responsibility
beyond that for your town and for your
city and for your state and you do that
all in as balanced and harmonious a
manner as you can and the spirit that
sub the spirit that infuses that entire
hierarchy and that stands at the top is
something like the spirit of goodness
itself and that's classically associated
with what is highest and that's
traditionally associated with God and
the identity that you have is all of
that stretching from lowest to highest
at once
and having understood that you now
understand something else you understand
what actually constitutes genuine human
flourishing at the psychological level
so one of the disservices that
clinicians have offered the general
Western world and the world at large as
a consequence of that is the notion that
mental health is somehow something
subjective and that's not true and we
know it's not true even though we don't
know that we know it and you know that
because there's no way you're going to
be mentally healthy if your wife is
miserable first of all she won't let you
be
and the same thing applies to your
children one of my neighbors in Toronto
said to me once a mother is never any
happier than her most miserable child
right and that's and so you can see in
that that whatever mental health
constitutes it's not exactly mental and
it's certainly not merely subjective it
has it's something that's much more like
the harmony that exists when the entire
subsidiary structure is performing all
of its functions as they should be
performed now Samuel talked about Samuel
andreev just before me talked about what
music speaks to us and that's what music
speaks to us it speaks to us of the
harmony that can exist in a complex
structure that's laid out in a properly
subsidiary manner where each note serves
the phrase and each phrase serves the
melody and each person who's playing in
the orchestra serves the overarching
function of the music and the music is
the Eternal dance between Chaos and
Order and that speaks to us of meaning
because that's where meaning is to be
found and that's the other thing to
understand about a subsidiary
organization you know we have so many
people in the world who are lost in ways
that are almost unimaginable with their
absolutely fragmented identities and
they have no meaning in their life and
they have no meaning in their life
because strangely enough the meaning in
your life doesn't emerge as a
consequence of your pursuit of your
proximal hedonic subjective narrow
purely self-serving goals and drives
there's nothing in that that's
nourishing and there's nothing in that
that's nourishing in part because unless
you can integrate yourself across a
large time span taking care of who you
will be in the future and simultaneously
fulfilling your social obligations in a
responsible manner the none none of the
nothing within the subsidiary structure
can operate properly much less you claim
the right to the gratification of your
hedonic desires that's a nonstarter and
even if you could do that you wouldn't
find in that the meaning that would
sustain you in times of trouble you find
the meaning that would and everyone
knows this you find the meaning that
sustains you in trouble when you need
for example to regard yourself with some
some positive attitude in the midst of
your stupidity and your suffering and
you can see in yourself the fact that
well at least you were in service to
your wife at least you had been useful
to your children at least you helped
take care of your parents at least you
were of some service to your friends or
to your customers to your business
associates to your nation you find that
meaning in service and that service is
in service of that Harmony that makes up
the entire Jacob's Ladder that stretches
from Earth to heaven and it's always
been that way and we offer our children
thin grol as a replacement for that
magnificent version of multi-dimensional
Harmony responsibility and beauty and
there's more to it than that too you
know I read the book the the the
biblical book that details out the life
of Abraham and I mentioned this when the
conference opened Abraham begins his
life with all his proximal hedonic needs
satiated and the voice of God comes to
him and says go out into the world get
away from what's merly infantile and
satiating and have the adventure of your
life and that's a good bargain because
we're built not for mere proximal
infantile satiation of our based desires
but to move out into the world like the
adventurers that we are and to face the
complexities of the catastrophic future
with a certain degree of nobility and
courage and to Hoist the world on our
shoulders and to struggle uphill and
it's in that struggle that the meaning
of life emerges if you lived your life
completely maybe it would justify itself
right if you could and where would you
find the meaning that justifies the
suffering in life and the answer to that
is well you find it in the burden of
responsibility because the burden of
responsibility isn't a burden it's the
greatest opportunity you could possibly
have and you know perfectly well when
you're trying to decide if your own life
is worth having that if someone comes up
to you even once and says you know what
you did for me it really mattered and
that might get you through like a week
of rough times just the mere fact that
it was obvious that the sacrifices that
you made in relationship to others
actually made a difference and you can
make a continual difference in your life
if you adopt the proper sacrificial
attitude right and it's the sacrificial
attit ude that makes the hierarchy of
identity possible because what you do
with the proper sacrifice is continually
sacrifice the lower to the higher you
continually you sacrifice your own meat
self-serving proximal hedonic whims to a
pattern of being that sustains you
across the long run and that unites more
and more people and it's a worthwhile
sacrifice because the payback for the
sacrifice
overwhelmingly what would you you say is
overwhelmingly disproportionate to the
cost and everyone who's had a child who
has any sense who's escaped from their
primordial narcissism understands this
because bringing a child into the world
and watching that person develop is a
bitter sweet Adventure because children
are fragile and things go wrong but it's
a very rare person whose head is set on
their shoulders and anything
approximating the proper manner who
isn't thrilled to death to see the
person they brought into the world
Thrive as a consequence of their
sacrifices and to see in that thriving
the justification for all the pain that
was associated with their
production and so and that's what life
is like and we don't let young people
know this anymore you know here's
something psychologists discovered in
the last 20 years there is no technical
difference between thinking about
yourself and being miserable
able those are the same thing and you
know that too you know if I'm on stage
and I'm talking to you and all of a
sudden I become self-conscious I drown
in anxiety and I lose my place right and
that's what's happening to the young
people that we see who are a drift
they're taught to be nothing but
self-conscious to do nothing but think
about their immediate needs to refer to
themselves as the Locust of all things
and there's nothing you could do that
would make them more miserable it's
identical with the instruction in misery
and you want to be outside yourself
serving a higher purpose and maybe
you're cynical about that but you can
think about it technically why do you
bring a fork to the table well so that
you can put a plate beside it and why do
you put a plate at the table and so that
you can set the table to serve your
family to share food to bring together
the people you love in something
approximating Harmony as a microcosm of
the entire Cosmic order and you can
replicate that at every level of
complexity all the way up to what's at
the Pinnacle and that's all real and so
is what's at the Pinnacle and we've
forgotten all of that and as a
consequence of forgetting that we've
forgotten the responsibility that we
need to bear in our life to make our
lives bearable and we've forgotten the
meaning and the adventure and the
purpose and the significance and this
and the earned self-regard that goes
along with that sacrificial attitude and
we've forgotten to tell our children the
same thing and we could remember we
could remember who we are we could
remember who we are and that's what this
conference was for to remind people
everyone who attends who you are right
you're the the
[Applause]
the
you're you're the men and women
individuals made in the image of God who
stumble eternally uphill towards the the
the Jerusalem on the hill the The
Shining City on the hill you know and
we're so foolish we regard those
propositions as something approximating
what primitive superstitions when in
fact they're the most brilliant
intuitions into the fun Al structure of
reality that have ever been offered
we've predicated our civilization on
those presuppositions and look at it
it's not so bad we've brought wealth and
plenty to billions of people around the
world we've been struggling uphill
properly and if we were wise and
faithful and courageous and responsible
we could continue to spread that to
everyone we could eradicate absolute
poverty we could bring about a time of
abundance and opportunity for everyone
and we'll do that that we can do that if
we Hoist the world on our individual
shoulders and operate collectively in
this harmonious Manner and continue the
struggle uphill toward the city of God
and that's the truth that's the truth
it's not some Superstition it's not some
primitive defense against death anxiety
it's not the opiate of the people right
it's the call to Divine responsibility
and to the degree that each of us acted
out in the confines of our own life we
do
what I suggested at the beginning of
this conference which is tilt the world
towards heaven and away from hell and
we're put this conference together to
encourage people to do exactly that in
the belief that it is in fact the people
who can do exactly that not only can but
must any attempt to circumvent that
responsibility merely brings about some
what would you say oscillating tension
between absolute tyranny and utter
slavery right as a responsible citizen
bearing the weight of the world on your
shoulders you obliviate the necessity
for the Tyrant and the slave and so
that's what we want to do and that's
what we encourage all of you to do and
to leave this coner conference thinking
deeply about what it is that you could
offer to the world if you threw
everything that you had into it because
life is a very difficult proposition and
you're not going to be the Glorious
success that you could be unless you
throw yourself into it utterly
wholeheartedly accepting it in all its
terrible expanse of catastrophe and
possibility and realizing in yourself
the person who has that Divine
responsibility along with all the rights
that are attended upon that to set the
world straight my sense is that if
enough of us enough of us realized that
sufficiently there's nothing we couldn't
accomplish there's no desert we couldn't
make Bloom there's no reason for zero
some malthusian pessimism right we could
have what we wanted if we truly wanted
it if we truly sought for it if we truly
asked for it it would make itself
manifest as a consequence of our faith
and our responsibility the adoption of
our proper identity and so you're
invited to do that as the individuals
the worthy individuals that you are who
were called to this place because you
had let enough of the light inside of
you out to shine enough on other people
so that your value was clearly made
manifest and we tried to gather 1500
people together who had done that
however imperfectly as we do such things
imperfectly to encourage them to
introduce them to other people with the
same abiding spirit and to see what we
could do with all the opportunity that
we have in front of us and so that's the
hope of
Ark on that note I would like to call on
someone
to remind us in the most appropriate
manner of what it is that we all have to
do when we leave
here